in the coming weeks sadly things are
likely to get worse before they get
better the chancellor's trying to
preempt
some of the economic damage but how is
our post-lockdown recovery going
well this chart shows you monthly gdp
the value of all products and services
in the economy
going all the way back to 2007. you can
see there that
huge drop in april as lockdown hit and
then
the economy beginning to bounce back
that line beginning to rise again as
things
reopened now we talk a lot about a
v-shaped recovery the hope
that things will bounce back to what
they were before if we take a closer
look at just this year
you can see that that v actually looks a
little bit more like a wonky u-shape
we saw record growth numbers in june
pretty good numbers in july
but growth of just 2.1 in august and
that's a worry
it's below what economists were
expecting and it signals that growth is
slowing even
in the least restricted month of this
year now the
service sector was a significant driver
of growth in august
and this is how different bits of it
performed the leader
clearly accommodation and food services
that's hospitality
now remember august was the month of eat
out to help out
this shows just what an impact that
scheme had
but it's over now much of the
hospitality sector faces new closures
we're not going to see this driver of
growth into the autumn
so how does the new extension to the job
support scheme
that the chancellor's just announced
compared to what came before
now he's consistently said it's not an
extension to the furlough scheme
but to many on it it will look and feel
pretty similar
on the original iteration of the
furlough scheme the government was
paying
80 of people's wages this time around
workers will get a little less
around two-thirds of their salary so far
so similar
but the scope will be smaller the
furlough scheme's always been open to
all businesses
and it's come at a cost of nearly 40
billion pounds to the government
we don't know exactly what this new
scheme will cost yet
but the treasury said it'll be hundreds
of millions a month
even at the very top end of that we're
looking at a cost of around
six billion pounds over six months as
you can see that's still
dwarfed by the original furlough scheme
the reality is that much much fewer
people will be applicable
it's just for the workers of businesses
mandated to shut
around three million british workers are
still on furlough it's very unlikely
all of those will be captured by this
new scheme there are still very tough
times ahead for many